we're you know going into the magical
side of the Marvel Universe and also
exploring a new dimension so it's very
exciting in that sense you wonder what I
see in your future
possibility
when I started on the film in September
2014 scott derrickson the director had
already started to gather a lot of
images and references from comics and
from you know films and photographs and
paintings trend establishing and define
what what the world of Doctor Strange
would be the Marvel films are produced
initially is a 2d film and then what we
do is convert them in post-production
into a 3d presentation 3d is it's a
whole sort of additional set of tools
for storytelling really you know it's
like taking a movie that's black and
white and turning it into color one of
the things we try to do with 3d is not
just keep it deep all the time if you
modulate then people really feel those
big moments and they and then you give
people a rest and then you really feel
another big moment we could leverage all
the modern computing tools that we have
available in making films to make it
really clean and a much more pleasant
viewing experience for the audience it
was a chance to venture into places that
we have never been and that's what the
multiverse gives us right weather is in
the magic mystery tour on in the Dark
Dimension with gamma more when we go
into the mirror dimension or the astral
plane it was a chance to do something
completely different than we had seen
before what they've done at imax is they
take in our movie and actually
reprocessed it to actually reduce the
noise increase the sharpness actually
enhance the presentation on a
shot-by-shot artist driven process we
also do additional color grading here so
it's like taking the movie and just
turning it up to 11 is really what we're
doing especially in a film like books of
strange I think having the extra size of
the screen and the resolution and all
the sound coming with it I think it's
way more immersive for the for the
audience it's almost like you're
enveloped by the image it's it allows
you to sort of like it's like the walls
disappear and I'm in it doesn't get any
better than that imax is delivering the
biggest canvas
is out there so it's an opportunity for
us to to tell this big epic story magic
and crazy stuff going on and do it in a
way that really does it justice we have
about 60 minutes or more of the film
that is in imax the film's 4matic [ __ ]
40 but for these special sequences were
going to the fool imax format which is
1.9 the idea was what can we do for the
story that will work for imax so once
that he arrives to the sanctuary and he
starts to learn to open his mind to the
possibilities then the frame opens up
when i was sitting for the first time in
the imax theatre even for me it was like
oh wow it was like a rediscovery of the
film it blew me away be careful which
past you travel down strange stronger
men than you have passed away we're not
doing it just because we can do it which
is doing it because it brings something
special to the film everything that is
available to us we use it everything
that is perhaps available we'll try it
and everything that is not available
we'll ask about it where were those kind
of people I spent so many years peering
through time
looking for you
you